mannequins
dick nannigans
dick nannigans
slush
dignanigans
ladies and gentlemen
please turn off your cell phones and
enjoy our production
of lunch with greatness
my my my what a beautiful day in
montgomery alabama
i swear the sun is so hot i nearly
melted indeed dr king but i suspect we
didn't meet here to talk about the
weather
indeed brother malcolm
unless of course we articulate that
the sun in this country shines brighter
on some than it does on others
yes but when the sun does shine on us it
is growing the seeds of revolution
i see your point brother malcolm but
do not those same seeds need to be
watered
with love
well i suppose that is the subject of
some discussion dr king
and i am all for discussion brother
malcolm
unless of course the words devolve into
proclamations of hate
well is that not
why we are here today dr king
to discuss
yes brother malcolm
and i am confident that as we discuss we
are going to discuss it
and discuss it
until
i say
that
our people have never resorted to
violence before the white man gave them
no choice but to pay him back in the
only currency he understands
brother malcolm
is that what you really have to say
at this point
in our lunch
indeed dr king
because we didn't land on plymouth rock
plymouth rock landed on us
[Applause]
okay well yes all right yeah i've heard
you say that before i
don't know why we're talking about rocks
when in fact it is the flesh and the
bone and the the dreams i have a dream
that someday our children will be judged
by the content of their character not by
the color of their skin
same for me same for me in fact i
believe that one day a black man will
become the president of the united
states of america
hopefully for eight years
oh of course it is of course it is
that's a given right
that's a given you know i mean but in
order to get there isn't he going to
need the help of our strong beautiful
black women
[Applause]
gotta respect the sisters
[Applause]
every single time
dick nannigans
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
it's amazing
i know
so
yes
[Music]
i feel like they're in my head
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
see going
[Music]
take nannigance
[Music]
dick manninghams
dick nannigans
dignantigans
slush
dignanigans
[Music]
gentlemen
exploded nut syndrome is a condition
indicated by the presence of exploded
nuts
which yours are
by the way i saw your show last night
amazing
intermission
you dead white person
oh this place does seem dope to me
martension
oh barely yo and tis about time
shakespeare duff scrivened a play that
places a brother amongst the firmament
that's my sight oh who's your favorite
character marzipan oh his mind as well
it's mine as well because they got
othello as a general oh
i'm saying alex yes and othello did the
beast with two backs without calmly
white maiden and it's not anyone
speaking against him
he's straight
me thinks things are looking up for
people of the darker hue damn straight
whoo
oh um
what's that i could borrow a couple of
duckets two purchases a k-pond from
yonder concession
more please you know i got a concealed
cornish game hand up in my doublet ooh
allow with me to part tickets up in this
[ __ ]
the second act is about to begin come on
y'all oh y'all heard the shirt oh if i
know shakespeare i thought i was about
to kill everybody up in this [ __ ]
[Music]
no no no
i hate it this way how they gonna kill
othello man that trifling ass iago i
knew he was up to something they should
have killed him in the first act how
they're gonna kill a fella and then how
othello gonna do himself in with a
dagger how does that happen let me tell
you something if a brother killed
himself every time he broke up with a
white [ __ ] this world would be bereft
of brothers you'll be talking to a skull
right now okay
where shakespeare is that chase people
oh ooh he's right there in knots away
okay
make way pretty make way be gone sarah
you killed othello a black man got it
going on and you shuffle off his mortar
coil i said unto thee that's a tragedy
oh tis that not the troubadour kanye of
the west what was oh not waiting
truth be told my lord
it is not i who penned this dreadful
play twist christopher marlow
thou already tried to use that line of
argument when the jews wanted to kick
your ass after the merchant of venice
we'd off not purchase it slick willy we
doth not purchase it be calm
my good lords it will not be long before
another black hero grace at the stage
and now if you let me take my leader not
so fast
you gonna write that hero
now
barely that [ __ ]
[Music]
one at a time
i put men like you behind bars every day
one at a time
you may take my years but cannot lock my
soul
away
all the years i had chased you through
this so long ago
your journey's out in the shadows
[Music]
first
i have stayed alive
[Applause]
[Music]
where did this [ __ ] come from i have no
idea one at a time
[Music]
[Music]
now this is just a joke
[Music]
things are getting worse taking what we
can from everything
[Music]
she knew
[Applause]
and we speak
[Music]
is the city on fire what's with all the
smoke
oh now we're all ears
oh
[Music]